yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah I hope that works now okay the game
before that and not pretty miserably but
it's not on video I had totally screwed
up my recording software with the
webkinz and I hope it works now I had
somehow Adam this is the actual you see
em you know want you to record the game
and once Hernandez I can switch between
the two and the analysis you was totally
screwed up okay next play I am anti duck
who the heck is that i am andrew brown
one okay now you played this opening
with 333 ec3 and 27 is the funny reply I
know it looks extremely strange but I
think black is just a pawn up here you
can basically at least objectively
speaking not play this opening with
white but yeah and lips you have you can
play many things that sir wouldn't use
immediately simply because it's blitz
chess there why does a porn down and he
has some compensation in terms of
development but the problem is a little
bit that the structure is extremely
sound for blacking and you don't really
see a clear way for white to do
something with this development h3 and
took sorry that looks slow
waiting in the moment down he castles
logs yeah okay um yeah let's do this
wonder if he wants to give up his bishop
that's not an easy decision it doesn't
want to now I can I could play defies
before and just say I'm attacking but
that's a bit loose now let's put it in
f 4g phones probably the idea
I have an idea that looks extremely
strange a six and 95 yeah i would like
to capture long what's not so easy to do
here okay it is slow but don't see a
direct problem
and he might be able to probably not i
play g5 take on HSN but yes I'm
threatening 93 m he's not going to table
okay oh let's go check also oh I was
saying that is a check that's a big big
miss Wow somehow i was thinking else to
recapture that he can take f6 oh that's
not good
and you have to take on f6 right is what
what else is there taking on c3 disease
right with the record position I think
okay
he takes that bow what's the idea I
thought now I just get like Queen 25
Bishop to b6 Quincy to I thought was the
only move player
40 from I thought you had to go d5 just
to have any sort of swindling idea
it'd just be five before this is an idea
and okay be 526 does not yet win okay i
can try this hook to be three or b-five
next
okay threatening would be too yeah so I
can check all just take jack then check
yeah I can hold the castle next Queen a4
know all rights it's exactly one checks
create a forward let's cancel check
okay empty three yan they're just creepy
three HS relatively easy play exactly
yeah so I think that objectively
speaking this opening is not correct
clearly seven is good it's really good
the compensation that white gets is not
sufficient here fall upon its again it's
always tricky in a blintz game but
objectively speaking it's pretty much
nothing Bishop before us maybe even
better it's okay i just wanted to play
relatively quickly we had an h3 used all
fairly slowly there was a run scary
moment where i just simply either had a
brain slip yeah 95 and g5 and and switch
this on I was somehow thinking night
takes III is a check which is kind of
strange this is the blood now I asked to
take on f6 of course that's the only
move that makes any sense and now the
situation wasn't clear i was thinking
gee takes f6 and now it's very strange
i'm attacking his nighttime limiting
revises cuddly now I'm two palms up
actually but all kinds of stuff hanging
and the engine wanted to do this this
this and gives violent advantage am I my
king position he has very shaky it was a
complete completely we at decision to
take on c3 LS I was just thinking as
check please and then after this it's
very weird to understand I'm just
getting better because now why
structures also wait with g5 and yeah
it's okay i thought queens into it's the
only move
gives any sort of hope okay I can take
g5 but but here why why is already bad
anyway and after this I just don't see
the idea 94 2d6 what the engine tells is
quite interesting so okay here you can
absolutely nothing no not the tutor also
going to change garrison wins now if you
play a 45 this queen is seven movers are
the nice thing now in d5 is of course
very ok at equal but 37 you can fight
for an advantage without any big yeah
you don't need to know all that much and
white also has to go for what we had in
the game I mean moves like this don't
help at all queeny's have look so good
we it but it seems to be strong it's
just what it is ok guys thanks for
watching